everyone uh again thank you for joining
today and i briefly want to introduce
kind of the the vision behind what we
are doing here with
the learn
portal so research is a
complex area where you have to
use your analytical skills but also use
your
[Music]
critical thinking and presentation
and so as you know on the learn portal
we provide a lot of training
opportunities for free as well as
very affordable
access to the different premium
coursework that we have
but ultimately what we envision
is that you can
transition from learning
into actual uh research project and so
this is what this research fellowship
was all about the research fellowship is
a program for those that already have
the basic training in bioinformatics if
you don't have any basic training in
bioinformatics you can reach out to one
of our team members and they can guide
you on how you can gain some practical
skills but once you've acquired those
practical skills the objective of the
research fellowship is to really think
about a topic where you can ask a novel
question and get the answers from data
and so briefly i will just show maybe
i'll share my screen
so
when you have created your profile um
and you have started your training as
soon anika mentioned you can get points
by completing courses which are going to
be found right here under your
profile you can see different courses we
have two types of courses
one type of courses are basic training
for example if you would like to
understand what is transcriptomics what
is machine learning what is statistical
analysis how to do it in r python or
using our big data analysis platform the
t bioinfo platform
you can search here for example if i
want to understand how to use python i
can search and i can find here a couple
of examples where i can apply
[Music]
this kind of scripting to analyze data
once you've completed this coursework a
lot of times you are interested in a
particular domain let's say oncology to
learn about these different projects you
will find a number of
projects so here you can see
project on modeling cancer precision
medicine or how to analyze tcga data the
cancer genome atlas so instead of just
learning about cancer and separately
learning about analysis of omics data
you get a paper that was published in a
high impact journal by an expert team
and you can analyze the same data that
they have used
following some steps that you should
already be familiar with and connecting
the logic of analysis to the research
question that was posed in that
publication so this project driven
approach allows you to connect the
biological questions with the research
challenges with the data sets and the
methods of analysis contextualizing
methods of analysis and really allowing
you to see the
impact of your analytical thinking
applied to a particular domain
after you've done that how do you know
that you're ready how do you know that
you can actually start applying these
methods to a dataset well as you know on
ncbi
for example there are many different
types of projects that you can find so
if we're talking about cancer maybe we
can talk about immunotherapy right and
now you start the process of thinking
how do i find a meaningful data set
where i can apply these skills that i've
acquired
and actually develop a research project
maybe you're already in a phd program or
you're in a graduate program and that's
a requirement for you to develop an
independent project well the best way to
do this is to try and think of a
specific topic that you would like to
focus on
how do you find the topic
finding a topic and developing from that
topic a research proposal using
bioinformatics using in silico analysis
tools can only work
either if you've spent a lot of time
thinking about this already or by
leveraging what other people have
published about it in other words doing
literature review and so what we have
developed here is also
a specific course
on how to design
a research proposal or a bioinformatics
research project and so this research
fellowship essentially goes through
key steps that you would have to take
to
first of all prepare literature review
then
identify a data set that could be used
to answer a particular research question
know how to summarize and explore your
data
perform in-depth analysis and identify
what are the most important findings of
this analysis that could be generalized
or could be used
and then also how to
turn it into a presentation that could
be peer-reviewed in other words somebody
who is
an expert or a novice
can look at the description of your
project can identify the data sets can
understand what you have done and will
be able to make reproducible results
similar to what you have done and that's
really the objective of this research
fellowship now what is the broader
impact what is the broader vision
well number one many experts in these
different fields do not have sufficient
time
to dedicate to analysis of other
people's data and as a result
every lab tends to focus on one
particular aspect
and they need to leverage the other body
of public domain data to inform their
questions
inform their decisions about what new
data to generate to generate and also
connect the data with the biological
understanding of that particular field
and so the research projects that we uh
put out from this research fellowship
program
are linked to some of the important
research projects that our company is uh
collaborating with researchers in
different universities on to help those
faculty and researchers inform
decisions about their research projects
so as a result of going through these
specific steps
publishing your project on learn getting
feedback from peers and then potentially
turning this project into a poster
presentation at a conference or a
research publication in a journal you
are contributing to the research field
and you are helping others
understand what data can tell them about
that particular domain
so
as you can see this course is a free
course that anybody can take so anyone
can go into this course without paying
anything and you can start thinking
about how do i search literature and
identify a project that i can work on
after that if you're a part of the
research fellowship we also organize
weekly sessions and today is an example
session where we actually go through
some of the findings and some of the
research fellows present their findings
for feedback get the feedback from
experts and from peers
and as a result refine their analytical
process to get reproducible and high
quality results
okay so
before we move on
i want to
ask if there are any questions if anyone
has any questions
uh about what i presented in my part of
this uh session and then afterwards i
will pass it on to dr harpritka or to
introduce some of the research fellows
that will be sharing their progress
today
so i see um one question or comment from
citizen naruti
he's saying my name is isaac nortoute
from ghana a postgraduate student of
center for food
technology and research benue state
university in nigeria
i am here to acquire transferable skills
and competencies in research to develop
impactful research and also network with
other research experts so great so first
of all welcome uh isaac
but also uh what we want to invite you
to kind of build these relationships
build on uh your research
skills is
essentially joining this research
fellowship program if you feel that this
is the appropriate type of program for
you
and
work with others to work on joint
research
if there are no other questions and and
okay so i do see a couple of questions
so
can we publish our findings for
international journal later after
completing this research fellowship so
the research fellowship is intended to
get you started or potentially complete
a project there are two options there's
a three month option and a six month
option
in the three month and there's actually
also shorter options available as well
if you have a specific requirement and
maybe you only have one month or two
months depending on your stage we can
obviously recommend the appropriate
length but thinking about a real
research publication if you would like
to publish in an international journal
there are several requirements for that
number one you do have to know what
you're doing and so you need some
training number two you potentially want
to work with an expert that can guide
you and shorten the time from some
general and non-specific questions to
focus on very specific things that you
would like to publish on and then
finally as the process of your
submission there are a lot of areas
where our expert team can help you
eliminate commonly uh
identified mistakes and kind of get to
that submission faster but we do
recommend at least six months for
somebody that would like to finish a
full research publication because it
does take time
okay question number two i am anand
shupla a btec biotechnology third year
student how can i be a research fellow
at this time
so again we even have high school
students so it doesn't matter that you
know what level of education you
currently have
the most important thing anand is you
need to be interested in doing research
and you need to understand that research
is a marathon it is not a sprint so it
will take time you need to have the
perseverance and you need to understand
that this is a complex journey research
is not a
tutorial you can't follow a tutorial to
do research research is open-ended you
can find answers sometimes you don't
find answers right so there's a lot of
things that you need to consider there
but if you want to join
this specific program you can join it
right here by going onto the programs
tab
and here
find research
fellowship right here research
fellowship
so nanika if you could please update
this image to have the title
and this is the program right so there
is a payment for this program but the
payment is to provide you with necessary
support and big data analytics platform
access so that you can process and
analyze big data now you can learn a
little bit more here about how this will
work by looking at the schedule and
after you've seen the schedule these are
just specific steps that we will follow
you can join at any time it's a rolling
submission this is a program that will
last throughout the whole fall if you
have any specific questions about timing
payments anything like that sonalica ray
will be able to answer those questions
okay can the researchers we work with
act as references for future phd
applications yes we have a number of
students that we have provided with uh
obviously based on merit right so
looking at your participation looking at
your activity we provide recommendation
letters and we do have uh uh experts dr
mohit mazumdar
or preet and others that have uh the
right kind of credentials to support
your phd application
okay sir i am from animal biology life
sciences non-research background and
don't know how to use bioinformatics
tools so can i take this course as a
beginner and further go for a research
project
you can moose gun but i do not recommend
doing that in fact i would recommend
first of all right
use your time and your
resources wisely there are a lot of
courses as i mentioned that are
asynchronous courses you take them
whenever you want to and however many
times
you have a small fee that you pay for
premium courses and the other courses
are completely free
start there create an account
go through some introduction to
bioinformatics if you are completely a
novice in bioinformatics or
look into a course called bytes and
molecules
so this course bytes and molecules for
anyone who's starting
will really put together all the
necessary elements
in place for you to be able to apply
bioinformatics in a particular domain
okay uh
my name is mukesh chand biowa nbi i have
completed masters bioinformatics from
central university of south korea india
there i accept
any fellowship after completing a
project
not sure what the question is maybe you
could clarify okay hello i am dr avi
rizzata phd from barc india i am here to
learn data analysis so that analyzed
research data and already reported
published researchers with the aim to
analyze the same data for giving
different interpretation very much
interested in applying for research
fellowship okay so
again the way you do this is you go to
the research fellowship program
your application
is essentially linked with
your readiness to start right it's a
process we have specific steps there are
requirements on time commitment and
requirements to join and you will see
today some examples of how to do that